[Music]
oh hi welcome back to careful boys
everybody we are currently off the
record and we're going to continue uh on
something that ended up being a
two-parter last time i the header on
that says how they smashed but it was
basically stories about how we met our
ladies i didn't like that
very misleading dude i wasn't here for
it but let's go but people loved it no
you were here it was so good
that we thought i was hiding from the
channel because of the luna
you were because we got rag the first
episode was stopping you telling your
story yeah i was telling my it was so
good that we had to do another video so
that anthony could tell his story no i
already told him nick could tell his
story i already told my story you guys
talking [ __ ] [ __ ] about kiting and
[ __ ] it was wholesome
that was part two right or part one i
don't know but then nick said his story
but it was so good we had to hear
tiff which is nick's wife's
version of it but why why was that why
do we tell you to go back just to recap
we went to like we were like friends for
a while
then she
asked me to be her date on like the
homecoming court or whatever right it's
[ __ ] lame i think that's stupid super
stupid yeah i hate it no no i hope it
dies
[Laughter]
what a cuck am i right what a cuck me
she asked me to go on a date um so i was
her date and stuff and at the time i
really liked her but i didn't know if
she liked me or not she doesn't she
doesn't to this day she still doesn't um
and she
throughout the night she was like
holding my hand like very being very
like lovey-dove and at the time i had no
experience with that and i was like yo
what the [ __ ] like this is crazy
there's a hand in my hand
wait again you're how old and i was like
i was like i was like 17 16 17 and i was
like my uncle's hands like oh yes this
is like this like like what's the move
do i do this like
the thumb grab yeah thumb grab damn dude
my thumb is big huh you got a big hand
timing thought man
[Music]
i could really hitchhike
so uh
during that process after
this is this is really fun this is where
the story gets really oh yeah yeah i'm
listening she's she was wondering if it
does
i drop her off and we're sitting there
in the car and i thought naturally we
would like kiss at the end of the night
when i dropped her off
but then we were both just so [ __ ]
awkward and so like inexperienced that i
just was like all right i'll see you
later and i'm sitting here and i thought
we were to lean in that moment never
happened and i just kissed her on the
cheek did you lean in and she didn't
lean she was just looking straight yeah
she looks straight i just kissed her on
the cheek and then she got out the car
and then the next couple days when i
would talk to her she was being kind of
avoidant she
wouldn't really like text me back that
much very short and it'd be like are you
mad at me or something is something
wrong you know you said all that oh dude
i love it i remember that age i remember
the day yeah yeah so [ __ ] can you tell
me just straight up
break it to me
and then the whole time she was kind of
avoiding me for a while
and i was like confused so that's the
part that i needed to get clarification
we didn't know either why she would yeah
10 years later so we gave him homework
so you never talked about this until 10
years later on the podcast like this is
where you cleared it up he likes to let
things marinate what's called a very
healthy relationship but they're married
yeah that sounds like but he's still got
it because they're married yeah but then
but there's still some secrets that need
to be revealed here on jk news the
problem is is that her reasoning was
very underwhelming not really juicy at
all she just was saying like at that
time
she was super inexperienced as well too
that she just was so like uncomfortable
and nervous about like
having a relationship she was just
generally nervous too yeah she just was
like and so it wasn't like a lame kiss
or anything like that nah she said that
[ __ ] was fire she didn't say that she's
like that kiss on the cheek was [ __ ]
fire yeah she was like that was the best
chicken
of my life i felt it in my teeth yo i
thought it was the back of my [ __ ]
the back
that's when you're hitting all the way
up in there behind the [ __ ] dude steve
was there when i asked a little tickle a
little tickle i facetimed steve so he
could uh accurate anatomy do you think
that's how the vagina works dude you
guys know your stuff
i was surprised i'm so glad we have a
consultant here
before for these moments do you want to
be our consultant
i think i should and she liked our mcb
clips
she loved it i was plowing her i was a
clowner right
yes
yes
that is exactly how you frame it
perfect
we made it
wait that's me in the back though every
time something's said she's like that's
good that's good wow really good guys
she's the director of just kidding news
she needs to be here forever
she's behind the cameras like that she
was like that's really good hey um nick
can you say that's gay or i'm gay or
something
don't worry i'll say i'll jump in we'll
work it in we'll do a pick up we'll do a
pickup
you think we could throw a zip or two in
there change up the vibe so someone just
went to anthony no no no no no please
we're on a roll here huh so long story
short the reason why she didn't react
and she how she the reason why she
avoided me was because she just didn't
know what was gonna happen next yeah she
loved me so much she was scared bro all
right cut the shoe what really happened
did she your wife could because you you
took some time you sat down and talked
with her it was like it was like a week
yeah it was like a week of us like kind
of
talking a little bit but very short yeah
and i was like very anxiety-ridden so
you're confusing what was going through
breaking backs everywhere she just said
like i just was nervous and i didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do so i just so
she froze up yeah she froze up a little
[ __ ] dude dude my sister was
perfect
my sister would go hiking with her um
you know now her husband but she said
that your hot sister my sister which is
she's married she's married yeah i know
tell me about it [ __ ] [ __ ] somebody
you let a good one go away dude damn you
did i had so i had the best end of all
time just so far
[Laughter]
what do you think what do you think
director
slowly turn to each other that's
disgusting push it on steve on the
monitors give me three give me three
we should have agreed to not laugh when
he started talking about that so kaitlyn
would be like but she wouldn't know is
he's [ __ ] serious this guy has a
hottest sister ever apparently no it's
like a joke but it's not i i still think
it's not real
but also real but also highly confusing
what they call a straight shooter and
truth teller thank you
so
kind of like you guys she was basically
a [ __ ] virgin yeah and like you know
what your sister yeah my sister and like
basically basically yeah basically and
like her dude too i mean she sat in a
bicycle seat a couple times but i think
she was a virgin yeah right so then my
my brother-in-law now
he would take her hiking and then uh
nothing would [ __ ] happen the whole
time and she's like if this [ __ ]
doesn't just kiss me yeah this is the
last straw because they did it like this
this is like five times they did the
dance yeah they're the dance five times
and so we're like in the forest alone
she's i even skinny dipped in front of
him and he didn't do [ __ ] he turned away
he closes out he's like i bent over i'm
picking up quarters then i'm picking up
smaller quarters
i'm picking so many acorns picking up
nickels then pennies i'm going for wait
i'm lost where the environment is
there's a bunch of coins that get tossed
in the fountain yeah you know what i
mean
by the waterfall when i was at asian
high school like i was probably what a
senior at that time i was surprised
people were having sex at our age i was
like
people we know you know i was disgusted
i was [ __ ] appalled
you were a registered republican
[Laughter]
it was disgusting it was on record too
right but yeah no then eventually they
they did it and then boom marriage and
all that she's like finally we finally
did it but i think it was kind of the
same nerve thing it's like
nobody knows what they're doing exactly
and honestly when you're at the wedding
watching them kiss was [ __ ] confusing
because they were still learning there's
still nothing there like
listen you gotta practice your wedding
kiss if anybody doesn't [ __ ] rehearse
their goddamn kiss at a wedding and
they're not like a
amazing kisser it's really awkward what
do you say about me and my wife's
wedding dude everyone needs to practice
we didn't rehearse
we freeballed it friendly neighborhood
advice from jk news practice your
wedding kiss it was very just
yeah
she was like
you kiss me on the channel because you
got her with a cheek kiss so you're good
she gotta get me back yeah
yeah return the favor or [ __ ] ten years
later you wanna do one of those things
we're about to kiss on the list and you
turn your cheek just so you can get it
back oh you're a man i got her bro
you're sneaky i showed her that's a nice
relief that really the only thing was
that she was also nervous yeah that's
cool that's what she said now it took
her 10 years to come up with this excuse
she's thought about it
you guys just came back from el salvador
right yeah and then you just threw it on
her like hey remember that time yeah i
was like listen here woman
[Laughter]
no we were going to dinner last night i
was like oh babe i got some homework i
have to ask you
what did you think when i kissed you on
the cheek on the homecoming date but she
remember that moment though and she was
like you were a [ __ ] she's like you're
all f-word that's what you're saying
she was like you were a [ __ ] and i was
like oh okay thank you did she say you
took too long nah she just said i was
nervous as [ __ ] oh she's like i didn't
know what to do but she wait what was
the second date what was the did you ask
her would you have been dtf that night
nah she wouldn't know for sure well text
her right now ask her yeah dude i'll
tell you no full written on facebook
today's video is brought to you by
babble
you know recently i've been traveling
with tycho again because he's older and
it's really fun to travel with them and
it's always been my dreams because he
really loves noodles
to go to italy oh so it'd be cool if i
could learn some italian eat some
noodles some pasta with him and be able
to speak the language and also teach him
stuff and how to say things properly
which i think babel is cool because
every single lesson is just 10 minutes
long to complete so that's something
that i can learn he could learn geo can
learn
and uh it'll be cool to like experience
not just the food but the culture too
yeah i think people are actually nicer
to you when you travel and you make an
effort to speak the language or practice
and you're not just there coming in like
an entitled american that expects
hamburgers all over the world yeah and
especially if you say like
fettuccine then they go in the right way
they're like
they're like come on man yeah don't diss
me like that and that's why babel's cool
cause they got the special speech
recognition technology that if you say
things the wrong way they can help
correct you and did we mention that
there's 14 different languages that you
can choose from that's a lot actually
they got german they got french they got
espanol you know i feel pretty awesome
about that yeah they got italian
so almost every major european country
you want to go to they can help you out
right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
off the record that's babble.com off the
record for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life a
better question is did she feel like you
was a [ __ ] because she asked you out to
the prom and now you asked because she
had to she answered why because you
would have never asked no it was part of
the she was on the court oh sadie
hawkins i was just saying haskins nah
she was part of the court and she needed
a date to take her
on can't someone still ask someone on
the court
like another dude could have asked her
no she needed someone that went to the
high school
to be her date but you're a prom king
right that was later bro oh okay never
goes later why are you bringing that up
oh [ __ ]
there's one person homecoming is in the
fall
prom is in spring okay there's no person
by the way that's a [ __ ] fact we have
no idea these are women's shoes
you wear you wear a lot of women's [ __ ]
we all know
yeah and then this fool has a [ __ ]
thong on too buns or kids yeah those
have a thong paired when you buy them
yeah it's a it's a white lacy that was
wearing a [ __ ] see-through underwear
right now let me see anyway he has a
crotch's pantyhose on right now
let's see your [ __ ] undies dude
really it's see-through let's see him oh
okay why do you show that backstage
like this those are
yo you actually i didn't even know they
had nan escaped underwear oh let me tell
you manscape underwear is the best
underwear around bro my girl bought me
like ten pairs yup does that mean she
had to buy ten shavers that came with
one free underwear wait i wanna know
[ __ ] ryan's story he's the last one
we never yeah and i know for a fact
she's not dead can we cut this manscape
promo real quick yeah promo code we out
here
mma we are sponsored by landscapes
use our promo code we need it good form
good form wearing those no my mine's
really uh
remarkable to me but oh my god you know
what i think i i met smack before you
did
can you let him tell this
how did you beat smack let's go
by the way let me tell you about your
story
joe's like let me tell you joe's like
shut up shut up let me tell ryan's story
okay you definitely met her before i was
dating her but we were friends for years
and she was just like a friend that i
didn't think
of in that way at all
oh really so do you when you tell her
that does she feel unattractive no it
wasn't that it's just like uh i think
she was just like a good friend
we met uh through mutual uh basically
she did tour she did world tour for how
to train your dragon like the live show
and she was that's time she was ashtray
she was astronauts
uh her alternate was a friend of ours
so when um
basically
when smack moved to la after that we met
her through our friend who was the
alternate astrid and she started hanging
with us she was in our circle she um
we knew that she was a dancer and that
she also did some like acro stuff so one
day
we were um this macro no we did a uh
back of the day quest crew used to do a
bunch of shows for nike where whenever
nike would come out with new material
like they had a new line or new shoe
before showing to the public they have
to show it to their own shareholders and
they would always try to do it in an
elaborate way so they have like a dance
performance with uh with all the new
gear on they'll just show only the uh
nike headquarters and then uh one of the
times that we were doing it they asked
if we could add girls to the show
and we were like hey girls like we've
never done that like one time you're
like
no girl's allowed
ill like we just don't do that and then
uh
we tried to think like who do we know
that is a girl that could do our stuff
and uh smack was a person that came to
mind because we knew that she did like
flips and you know was just like a
trained dancer and stuff so we asked her
to do it and then uh so we went to
portland did the show and i was just
hanging with her just as a buddy and
stuff we stayed just regular friends
super platonic never even thought about
that
until uh she was thinking about it the
whole time just fyi she told me really
she actually really no she'd been horny
she actually was like there was never
one time that like someone on her side
was like hey you know smith likes you or
like i like her like that never happened
until uh
one of the halloween parties i remember
she was dating a dude and she would
bring this guy to like the parties at at
our house and then
we had the quest annual halloween party
which is like a really like big thing
for us and then that was fun i expected
her to bring that dude and i was like oh
um there's the dude beat him up right
but uh
but he was there with a different girl
oh really and we don't know him like
that we know him only through her so
it's like why are you here if you're not
exactly so i was like oh hey dude what's
up and then smack came later like by
herself and i was like yo what the
[ __ ] going on and she was like uh yeah
um
so today like i just found out that uh
he is back with his ex today yeah
but let's go to the party that is of
your friends
right wow because i want to [ __ ]
clown chase the lmfao and the [ __ ]
quest crew and is he there and he's like
he's like hey no hard feeling sweetheart
yeah sure
[Laughter]
she was like
do you know john tracy laptop
the uh so what happens is even at that
point i wasn't thinking anything yet and
i i just i remember i felt really bad
and uh because she's so nice and i was
like dude uh after the party's done like
let's like go get ice cream or something
i just wanted to cheer her up somehow
because i just felt super sad and then
um
after the party was over we went to like
rite aid and just got ice cream right at
ice cream's good bro thrifties baby
hell yeah and i had a date too i had my
own date at this party kicked her to the
curb right yeah
hey sweetheart guess what no hard
feelings
how did you go that's what i said
so what what happened there you didn't
bring her along you're just like hey
look my friend's doing a bad time
thinking i gotta go do the thing with
her and was it chocolate malted crunch
was it the chocolate malted crunch
that's the best one
right i haven't tried that uh the date
that i was with wanted to like keep
partying so oh it works out great i was
like all right they're gonna go do some
other [ __ ] uh i'm just gonna go lay low
and then we're gonna go like just i
should be kicking it start a
relationship yeah and then start chapter
one of that whole thing so then we even
then i wasn't thinking anything and then
did the ice cream go like this
you want to try ice cream
it's the same one i was eating
i was just eating this one
[Laughter]
why did we do this why did we do this
it's romantic dude
sorry it's like lady the trap it's just
ice cream before they do this they're
eating it off a balcony
yeah
that was the third beat of that one all
right we're done we're done with that so
yeah so we're just laying we're just
laying there talking and then uh
literally within that there was no zip
uh within that like
i guess like it was like we almost we
hung out like six or seven hours or some
[ __ ] like that whoa
yeah just talking nonstop and it just
clicked and you're like damn dude i know
you were so cool still telling a story
before him and then
i got a support and i think the most the
most important part is that throughout
my entire life like i had never
been with a girl that was just a friend
like it's every girlfriend i've had was
someone that i was initially attracted
to upon first sight oh yeah and i was it
was like it was like mission you know
like what they were just a girl
sometimes there were girls but not but
not a but not a girlfriend
good lord
next next on oxygen i see where that's
at and i like it i like it a little bit
it's actually thoughtful and deep [ __ ]
yeah
i didn't realize how like how much more
substance there was in that yeah and
then uh we're on this side of the table
next level [ __ ] we believe all women
yeah bro
not the rest of you guys
so yeah that's literally that was the
foundation of our relationship we just
uh so you took it slow from there it was
extremely slow it was just like
friendship and then when did it hit you
like when did it hit you were like i
love this girl man did you guys [ __ ]
slow no it was the uh
what was it pent up [ __ ]
like i've been loving you this whole
time i didn't really really but it was a
combination of both well even that
didn't come that didn't come until like
that didn't occur until like way later
too like it it was very slow that's so
sad three months six months six hours
worth of just touching and [ __ ] maybe
like a month or two or something oh
that's that's still a month or two of
just getting to know each other you are
a gentleman bro but what was that what
was the moment for you where it was like
uh past hanging out past friendship oh
and you're just like you know what okay
okay i'll take it it's gonna sound
really like cheesy but uh
um
one thing i know she ate her ice cream
one thing i noticed about her is that
she doesn't uh when i when we would talk
about our like history and like x's or
whatever it always sounded like somebody
um didn't make her feel special or like
did some like kind of what happened at
the party like i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
happens a lot so i wanted to like um if
i was gonna tell her that i i was in
love with her and like and i was at the
time i didn't want to just be like i
love you like in the same places that we
always were so i wanted to make
something like kind of monumental and
then so the way i did it was the what
made her ice cream that is the blackest
thing
like in science class looks like a bag
of ice he's rolling it with a toy thing
he's like five minutes i'm telling you
it's gonna be pretty good
just give it some time yeah she's
getting both get diarrhea
[Laughter]
ran out of ice so i only got one room
for one but we just split it i made a uh
so like back in the back in the day at
that time
i
in my car whenever we would get in the
car and drive
uh for some reason my car would default
to the same exact like track that was on
my usb
and it was like every time you get in we
know it's gonna what it's gonna sound
like uh same old song i made this like
uh
hour-long
radio show so it sounded like it was the
radio oh
ryan is the most thoughtful guy i have
ever met little [ __ ] just [ __ ] silk
city right now
no so that excited so in the beginning
it sounds like it's that same song
all right but she turns it off but then
i did uh
wait wait wait i [ __ ] hate this song
can we get a new ad hey can we get a new
station
[Laughter]
literally i'm out the car
it's an hour-long like actual radio show
and all the tracks are mash-ups made of
all the songs that have been in all the
jobs that she has worked on since she
started working in l.a
yeah so it's all the commercial how did
you know did you go on her imdb or some
[ __ ] well she has a she has a commercial
reel that's like insanely long of all
these jobs and then i just ripped all
the songs from this including the indian
song that she was a part of the one no
not from the game that's how it started
and just all the songs she likes and
then it's that radio show is complete
with commercials and [ __ ] that are all
inside jokes that we've had whoa was she
listening to it like oh my gosh so we
were sitting in the car for an hour was
she like 40 minutes in like this is
excessive yeah she was slowly she was
just like she was weeping and then uh
and i had timed it so that at a point in
the show
uh we call in live like from my phone
and then i can talk to the dude on the
thing and then like it's it's free it's
like pre-recorded so that i'm it sounds
like we're talking about something we
rehearsed it we're doing it yeah i
rehearsed it and then i rehearsed the
timing so that on this drive that we
took at an exact point in the radio show
we end up at this like cliff make out
point yeah and then that's where i told
her is that why it's an hour long
because you timed the drive on [ __ ]
and i had to like rehearse the drive and
that's when you lost your virginity
no that's that's that's the first time i
told her that i loved her like was i'm
so glad we saved this to the end
of course
ryan always tops all of our shitty
stories dude
we should just be friends
i like the way we are
we should be friends
it's all the whole thing's on soundcloud
like
yeah anyone could just like downloading
it yeah and link in bio can we can we
get the link
that's amazing free asset but there's
parts that are missing from me because
some of it's supposed to come out of my
phone because like you know where it's
supposed to be like
right yeah and then and then just hire
ryan for that part and then at the end
of the radio show like her her best
friend at the time like calls in and
like says nice things about her [ __ ] oh
yeah it's one of those things so what
the hell how are you going to make a
proposal now that shit's crazy that
alone is like it beats so many people do
it in reverse
drive in reverse
[ __ ]
all right all right okay ready ready
she's like this isn't romantic this
isn't sweet
you're being weird he shows up to his
own halloween party with her
ex-boyfriend and his new girlfriend that
would top it technically
it's in reverse
let me see if i can um find a little bit
so you can hear what it kind of sounds
like damn ryan you're the most
fascinating you've seen a gem you are a
best man
i was gay again oh dude i'd marry you in
a heart number one on my list that's got
to be the gayest way to do it all right
what's your proposal to all of us go
yeah
yeah i don't even know how to think in
those terms that's amazing it's just
called um care the commercials okay some
of the commercials
if your day is anything like ours you're
sitting legs up at an armchair with a
coffee in his hand ready
and he did this for fun
also professional musical producers and
stuff so i was able to do this this is
like a gta radio station it is it's
better it's 56 minutes long and it's got
like it has like
he's complaining because one of the
radio commercials is for this guy who
steals cars
and basically like her car got [ __ ] up
so basically the i'm the thief that like
[ __ ] with it
and then and then he calls in to like
ask them to take the commercial off
because it's incriminating it's like a
butcher it's like a whole [ __ ] thing
but
it's like it's like a play it's like an
hour-long play
yeah but
yeah it's up there if anybody wants to
[ __ ] listen to that [ __ ]
i mean we we we have them here you can't
i don't no need we don't need to keep
them anywhere else no we gotta be making
movies this guy sucks dude
your dad should listen to it and get
some feedback from a problem he's gonna
be like this sounds amazing i'm super
wet right now so that's that's a story
about like yeah from that day on then uh
yeah that's how you got her so she gonna
take your last name email
makime
dude imagine this chick is cheating on
him every [ __ ] night
every morning afternoon and night
oh my god after all of that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you